as well-known financial institutions and
organizations add bitcoin to their
balance sheets cryptocurrency is always
in the news stable coins which are less
volatile cryptocurrency assets have
recently caught the attention of
investors
theta is the most popular stablecoin
tether is the third biggest
cryptocurrency in the world by market
value
but what makes it unique and how it
became so popular
well hello
i'm shamley and i welcome you all to
this new video of simply learn on what
is tether in which i will take you
through its various aspects and will
also help you explore your answers for
tether
in this video i will take you through
first
what is tether then we will explore if
tether is a stable coin
after that we will understand why it is
controversial
and then we will understand
how does tether works
then we will look into the users
followed by what makes it unique
and then we will explore how to buy it
and at last we will explore is it a good
investment
so without any further delay let's start
with the video
so let's start with what is tether
tether is a blockchain based
cryptocurrency that tries to keep
cryptocurrency prices stable it is
utilized by crypto investors who want to
avoid the high volatility of other
cryptocurrencies while still maintaining
value in the crypto market
theta tokens which were created by the
crypto exchange bitfenix and trade under
the usdt sign are the native tokens of
the tether network usdd is the fifth
largest cryptocurrency by market
capitalization with the value of around
68 billion as of october 2021
so is tether a stable coin
the stable coin industry strives to
eliminate volatility allowing bitcoin to
function as a safe have rather than a
dangerous investment in a volatile
cryptocurrency market where it would be
difficult to convert back and forth
between cash and a cryptocurrency like
bitcoin
stable coins provide liquidity
so tether is indeed the world's first
and most well-known stable coin
true usd paso standard and usd coin are
some of the other stable coins on that
market
other stable coins on the other hand use
other sorts of collateral
some are backed by fiat currencies such
as the euro or the yen while others are
backed by commodities like gold and
silver
so
why is it controversial
tether originated in 2014 as real coin
and the first tokens were released on
the bitcoin network in 2015.
it was one of the original
cryptocurrencies as well as one of the
first stable coins to be successful
however as quickly as it gained
popularity it was met with mistrust and
controversy which is understandable
given how closely the coin was
scrutinized as the first popular
stablecoin
tether was a driving element behind
bitcoin's bull run up to twenty thousand
dollar in 2017 it appeared that tetter
was being artificially injected into the
cryptocurrency market to provide
liquidity
also tethers parent firm was charged by
new york attorney general lelithia james
of concealing a 850 million dollar loss
by dipping into tethers currency reserve
in 2019.
tether has reached an agreement with
james to pay 85 million dollar and stop
dealing with new yorkers as of 2021.
now let's come and look into how tether
works
tether limited
the tether token reserves and accepts
fear deposits and withdrawals
it also means and destroys tokens to
keep the coins value stable
so tether on bitcoin
was created on the omni layer a bitcoin
blockchain based system a ledger is kept
on the bitcoin blockchain as well as
liquid
a bitcoin sidechain and transactions may
be seen by omni explorer
theta on other blockchain platforms
tether is also available on ethereum
throne and eosio among other blockchains
as a result new assets can be developed
directly on these platforms
ethereum happens to be the largest
market for usdt
come let's look into the uses of tether
tetra has established itself as a
necessary component of the
cryptocurrency markets currently crypto
trading pairs priced in usd and other
stable coins outnumber those priced in
u.s dollars to be more specific there
are three most common use cases
first is trading
to reduce fees and wait periods user can
convert the cash they need for trading
to usd and then use it to buy other
cryptocurrencies
second is lending
because lenders do not have to worry
about losses due to volatility usdt is
extensively used as a lending asset
third is cross-border payments
international money transfers from or to
any area of the world can be completed
in minutes
that's that makes me wonder what makes
it unique
stable coins assist traders and
investors in reducing the danger
associated with the severe volatility
that is typical in cryptocurrency
markets
by moving value to usdt a trader might
reduce their risk of exposure to a
sudden drop in the price of
cryptocurrencies
also they enhance the number of trading
pairings they can offer by facilitating
shipped to crypto transfers furthermore
it permits merchants to treat
cryptocurrency in places where fear
currency is prohibited
so how to buy tether
binance coin spot bitfinex and kraken
are just a few of the famous
cryptocurrency exchanges that accept
tether tokens you can just exchange them
with other cryptocurrency or buy them
with any type of currency
so this brings us to a question is it a
good investment
tether is the most popular stable coin
with no significant competitors even
when compared to other cryptocurrencies
not just stable coins it perform
admirably in terms of market
capitalization after seven years of
prosperity there are no signs of it
slowing down it is currently one of the
crypto space too big to fail enterprises
however don't expect it to appreciate in
value
that is precisely the purpose usd is
kept at one dollar and the organization
behind it aims to keep it there
tether is a helpful tool but it is not a
typical investment
well this was all about tether
do tell me what are your thoughts on
this popular star of crypto market
so we have almost reached the end of
this video if i missed anything
important do let me know in the comment
section i hope you enjoyed this video on
what is tether and learn something new
from it if you like this video then
please do hit the like button thanks for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more updates and videos from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here